[Music]
reporting on the war christian bale
stars in the first major motion picture
about the armenian genocide that took
place over 100 years ago armenian stars
share Kim and Kourtney Kardashian showed
their support posing on the carpet
together
Kim giving us a major 70 share moment
with her new do ya well what goes around
comes around
et spoke with the goddess of pop on the
red carpet in Los Angeles where she
opened up about what the film means to
her no one knows about the genocide so
so it's it's important that people know
share also gave an update on her
mother's health the star recently
dropped out of a Lifetime TV movie to be
there for her
my mom is really great you know my mom's
91 and she's fabulous she has to worry
about just a few things about getting
pneumonia and that's the thing we I
worry about the most
et also caught up with Christian Bale
where he revealed which celeb he was
most excited to see if the premiere I
would have to be share waiting there I
would hope you said thing that that's
for my mother-in-law she's hearing she
said she was very excited to see Shane
[Music]
you